all right so I just got done reading the
material for this week's video and why
didn't no one tell me that this story
was like the best thing ever on a number
of occasions during the read-through
this week I pause either to cry or to
cheer and after every subsequent cheer I
was reminded that I was sitting alone in
a dark room our grandparents fought in
the Second World War and now I'm reading
one piece every generation has its big
challenges and this is mine I guess I've
still got over 900 chapters to read and
as I've said since last week I've been
reading through chapters 69 to chapter
100 oh and to ensure I remained spoiler
free anime AJ everyone's favorite Mouse
wielding good boy has been on my behalf
reading your comments and sending them
to me this episode marks my second step
into my one piece journey and as many of
you fans of the series already know this
week were in for a treat I'm totally not
mark and this is my review of one pieces
are long Park and Loeb town
[Music]
our long Park chapters 69 to 95 I want
to get this out of the way first this
arc is to an absurd degree superbly
written and I say that not because Oda
has done anything revolutionary in
isolation but because he's executed so
many small isolated scenes that exchange
is leading up to this arc It's Made
executing this part of the story look
effortless in terms of writing what
would Luffy do in the situation we don't
need to have that explained or justified
to us because we've already seen Luffy
develop across this adventure for the
last 68 chapters we know him
what would Zorro do in this situation
it's obvious because we too know this
character in and out I touched him this
in the prior video but it's worth
repeating because I think it's the key
to why this arc worked as smoothly and
supremely as it did every character
that's part of Lupe's crew right now is
completely understood by the audience
without reading a single word of the
hour-long Park arc try saying that 10
times fast and if I didn't make it clear
already this is the best act of one
piece I've read so far without question
our long park deals largely with the
character of Nami who if you paid
attention to the last review video was
the only character of the main five not
to receive a somewhat clear backstory
Sanji was it cooks apprentice that met a
nice pirate guy got hungry and turned
into an emo chef with a hankering for
kicking Zorro was always the second best
swordsman as a kid in his village and
found on his rivals grave to become the
best swordsman in the land Luffy was a
headstrong kid that learned a valuable
life lesson about sacrifice thanks to a
friend
too bad that happened after he stabbed
his face and whose Upland how to be a
more honest person both to others and
himself and while nanny's story in
orange town with buggy did have
something of a resolution it was
intentionally left open by Oda for the
specific purpose of exploring it right
here and it's amazing this particular
section of the story called hour-long
Park picks up right after the events of
the last one and follows a fleeing nami
as she returns home after attempting to
leave everyone behind and the story
that's told here is nothing short of
spectacular for those of you that are
familiar with my reviews you'll know
that I'm rarely this nice so why does
this arc work as well as it does for me
in a word it's focused the entire
plot of this arc centers around Nami her
journey back to her Island home
the tragic backstory she has and the
resolution that follows no point as the
plot deviate to something that is
impertinent to the story in one form or
another and every piece of dialogue in
typical oda fashion either in forms or
furthers the story be it through
carefully crafted exposition or world
building whether it be through nominees
initial unveiling as being an actual
pirate officer working under our allah i
did not see that coming or the guys
discussing and revealing more about the
grand lines seven warlords and the
baggage that comes with that it gets me
pumped to see what's coming next because
i know i likely won't expect it which is
a super nice thing to experience when
reading a shounen manga especially when
you consider this one was written in the
90s when nami herself arrives on the
island it's revealed that a set of
communities live there also and
particular care is taken when explaining
where these places are in relation to
one another the main stronghold of the
island and home to the villain of this
arc are longg is called hour-long park
it's a repurposed one-time naval base
now leveraged by our long to bribe the
governing bodies of the east blue to
remain an official presence in that
region this isn't necessarily dealt with
in detail in the arc but this is our
first hint of politics in the story and
there's more to see here I'm sure
immediately next to airline park is
cocoa village this is where Nami grew up
in a small house surrounded by a
tangerine growth on the outskirts of the
larger cocoa village town this is cute
because I love that the very first time
Luffy sits down to talk with Nami back
in Orange town she says that she likes
two things money and tangerines I
remembered that fact and when I saw the
woman living in that home I knew that
she had to be connected in some way to
Nami given that she is surrounded by
tangerines it's simple about little
things like that acting as clues for the
future are a nice touch I think in the
coco village town there's a strong sense
of community there as we learn that our
long enforces a protection tax on the
local similar to how the Mafia and other
gangs across the world imposed their
will on their communities in a nutshell
if they don't pay bad stuff happens and
that bad stuff is not told to us but
shown to us in the rules of their
neighboring town and furthest village
from our LAN Park ghosa with our long
Park Gosa and cocoa village we quickly
get a firm grasp and understanding of
the dynamic and power structure at play
in this story
through the ending of the last arc with
Nami looking at the bounty picture of
our lung were led to believe that she's
going to claim that bounty for herself
and make off with the money however we
quickly realized that not to be the case
when it's revealed that she's an officer
working under our lung which as I
alluded to earlier took me completely
aback and I thought it acted as a really
nice little subversion it's here we are
introduced to our lon the character with
which the park he resides in is named
after and the namesake of the arc itself
he's immediately built up as this
monstrous threat and the most
intimidating villain our heroes have
dealt with yes he's responsible for the
destruction of ghost village and is
extremely elitist with regards to his
race of people considering himself and
his army of fish men several rungs above
that of humanity with their abilities to
breathe both on and off land as well as
an increased level of strength that far
out matches our own he considers
humanity a lesser being that naturally
needs to serve Him hearing this I was
very interested to see what this
character and his subordinates had to
offer in the way of combat for the rest
of the cast and in addition to that the
dialogue that Arlen himself spouts is
filled to the brim with everything from
quiet confidence to explosive anger he's
most definitely an interesting character
that I was eager to explore I'd hear
from more and all that information we do
eventually get to explore is provided
through the lens of Nami story and life
which I thought was an inspired choice
the real meat and potatoes with this are
comes in the form of Nami as I alluded
to earlier with the most eye-opening
segments for us being that offer origins
story how she came to be in Cocoa
Village and her expressed motivations
that have driven her to work for this
despicable sea scum known as Arlen
through flashback Oda uses this as yet
another opportunity to reinforce the
characters and area of cocoa village
that have already been introduced to us
those being Genzo and more importantly
logic Oh Nami stepsister but also to
widen the scope of the world just that
little bit more using the character of
Bella mare an ex-military soldier who on
returning to the island did so on the
verge of death carrying in her arms a
baby Nami and a three year old no Chico
the flashback details the circumstances
surrounding Nami no Chico and her
adoptive foster mother Bella mare during
which a somewhat large conflict emerges
between Bella mare and the young Nami
before she eventually storms off
shouting that she's sick of being poor
and that Belle
isn't her real family or mother when she
reaches the center of the town she
encounters Genzo who in a number of
words explains to her how much Belle
Amer loves her and her stepsister
the emotions Nami is feeling here are
obviously just a combination of
frustration and childhood naivety but
eventually this choice manifests itself
into one of the biggest mistakes of her
life as Nagi ko goes to bring Nami back
home our along arrives to collect the
protection tax fifty thousand berries
for a child and one hundred thousand
berries for an adult knowing full well
that Bella Mara doesn't have even
remotely enough to pay for both herself
and the kids she decides to instead of
pretending she doesn't have children
outs herself as their mother their real
family and pays to protect them leading
to her unfortunate death at the hands of
Arlen it's a tragic scene and in
discovering that Nami has a talent for
mapping lands and ocean charts which had
been revealed earlier in the flashback
hour-long elects to keep Nami
by his side and from that very young age
Nami decided to lean completely into
this role Arlen has provided for her on
the condition that if she can come up
with 100 million berries she can buy her
villages freedom this choice of course
forces her to turn her back on everyone
to pretend that Bella mares death meant
nothing to her all in a humble effort to
try and control the situation and work
towards a solution for her community and
from the very beginning of this arc from
the moment she arrives at Arlen Park she
resumed her work alongside Arlen and his
forces exuding the demeanor of
everything is under control but things
are most definitely not under control
despite her at times genius efforts to
preserve the status quo
she is operated under for the best part
of a decade the interruption to the
status quo of course takes the form of
Luffy Zorro who sought Sanji as well as
the two bounty hunters along for the
ride yo suka and Johnny and this is by
far and away my favorite aspect of this
tale the conflict that emerges between
Nami and the straw hat crew after they
arrived to rescue and help her
at the beginning of this story we know
that Luffy is travelling a little behind
everyone we know that Nami arrived from
the island first and we know that the
raster is a ship right behind Nami
however through high jinks and bad luck
the group consisting of Johnny Zorro and
a sob gets split up leading to us as Oro
and Luffy all being separated towards
the beginning leading to them
individually meeting Nami acting under
our lock which ends up being intensely
interesting the Zorro is first up as
he's thrown in front of our along and
eventually Nami the dialogue between the
two is tense but fascinating with my
favorite part coming from Zorro testing
Tommy's claimed that she was always
lying to them and that she never really
cared about them by throwing himself
into the water front to drown this
naturally forces Nami to come to his
rescue proving to him that she really
isn't as bad as she said that she is
laying the groundwork for a perfect
little bit of dialogue between the two
Nami saying if you mess with me again
you're dead what's with all these
bandages Zorro then she Cleary marks I
ran out of clean laundry which is a
wonderfully character appropriate but
subtle callback to an exchange the two
shared acts ago I love that
later in the story Musab is also placed
in front of our line at herself in a
similar circumstance although this time
OSAP has been apprehended after trying
to protect a pounds person from danger
in Cocoa Village in this scene things
become even more heated as not only is
yousef not as emotionally intelligent as
Zorro and therefore can't see Nami as
anything other than a traitor but the
army of Fishman beneath our lawn now
don't fully trust Nami due to her out of
character rescue of Zorro chapters prior
and so to prove her loyalty she
seemingly attacks and stabbed Zeus up
drawing blood before throwing him into
the waterfront to drown and bleed out
when I saw this my jaw hit before I
flood believe that she actually did this
but in actuality it's later revealed
that she stabbed her own hand in an
attempt to get her reputation back and
to protect us up from danger this reveal
then was made all the better by the fact
that the manga gave me tons of
opportunities to notice her bloody and
gloved hand before it's eventually
revealed what it actually happened know
that is some great stuff but by far and
away the best character interaction in
this entire arc comes right after this
and it is I actually don't even have
words I've mentioned this a number of
times throughout this review so far but
the entire story surrounding this arc
has been through the lens of Nami and
how she herself is doing everything in
her power to control the situation so
that no one else needs to die she's
terrified of are alone but she's smart
enough to find a way around us and
throughout this arc when faced with
situations by Zorro and Asaf she has
found genius ways of navigating this and
you could only imagine what else she
must have done throughout the last eight
years she's dedicated her life to our
line and over the course of this
regrettable career she's had has amassed
almost a full agreed amount of money to
buy her village and her own freedom from
him however she makes a fatal mistake
when she lets all know that she almost
has the full amount and should have the
remainder very soon in hearing this he
sends a corrupt naval crew to reprimand
Nami and in doing so takes every last
bit of her savings as she goes back to
confront aerilon about this luffy is
having his own issues after finally
arriving and reconvene
with his group he is confronted with
accusations of nummies betrayal and
utter dislike of their group Luffy
definitively never believes a single
word of this and even when asked
straight up to leave by Nami herself he
elects to fall flat on the floor to
sleep he isn't leaving things continue
to unfold an hour long exposes that he
has no intention of ever allowing Nami
to go free and that's when the reality
of the situation crushes her causing her
to run away now in a flood of tears
crushed by the weight of her
circumstances realizing that she's
pushed everyone away for seemingly now
no reason at all and that all of this
effort has completely 100% been a total
waste of time
she collapses to the floor overcome by
emotion trying to cut off the tattoo she
got to demonstrate her allegiance to our
lon and this is when Luffy walks up to
her one last time her initial reaction
is to scream at him to leave to do what
she says Luffy acknowledges this but
still does nothing she pauses and in a
final moment of what I could only
describe as complete and utter
desperation she turns to him and cries
for help
[Music]
this lion hit me so hard because you
know that this is said only out of
absolute despair and what makes it all
the more powerful is that despite being
told to leave being told that Nami
doesn't like them anymore and that
despite her insistence that she doesn't
need them or him Luffy without
hesitation places his hat on Nami's
quivering head reassuring her that he
will see to this being fixed he makes
his way back to the crew who clearly
have all this time been waiting for the
go-ahead from Luffy they are a loyal
group that are there to protect each
other loving friends to the bitter end
no matter what happens this exchange is
possibly the most pure and wonderfully
touching thing I've ever read in manga
and I think a goes without saying
brought quite a few tears to my eyes
made all the more touching when I
remember when he first met Nami he said
not to touch his hat and yet now he
elects to give it to her
to keep safe indicating visually to us
that she has his complete and total
trust and given the things that she said
to him earlier in this arc that act is
made all the more poignant and this
brings us up to the fight scenes and oda
manages to give each character in the
crew fighting for nami a utility in this
mini story and battle that are not only
fulfilling for those characters but
specifically don't make them feel like
Luffy's lesser which i think is vitally
important especially in a show like this
and what i find to be the most
impressive is two moments from this
fight scene actually got me to jump out
of my seat and say yes so let's jump it
immediately following that reaffirmation
of friendship and trust comes a massive
fight scene to cap off the arc
if I were to divide it into sections I'd
say Luffy's opening statement would be
the first the second would be the gang
support and backup followed by and
finishing off the arc with luffy's final
battle with Darla and by far and away
the most interesting and compelling
moments from this fight for me have to
be the contribution supplied by Sanjay's
Oro and OSA with each character serving
a critical part of a narrative in this
scuffle what aspect I am always
terrified of whenever I read Shonen or
experience the genre is that of the
secondary character effect Xaro and
sanjay both have strong fighting
abilities but with them not being the
main characters themselves oftentimes it
falls into the lap of the main character
to clean up their messes or supplement
their limitations in other words in
other Shonen they are often there to be
the sidekick to the main character to
make them look better but one piece
doesn't do this in the slightest or at
least hasn't done so yet Zorro fights
bravely and finally while also having a
tilted excuse of still healing from the
attack from Hawkeye in the player and
Sanjay pretty much single-handedly saves
the damn day by freeing Luffy from the
rumble beneath the water while also
dealing with
Dishman but what order does it Pusa is
my absolute favorite as the character up
until this point had yet to be presented
with a moment to truly prove himself
throughout this arc he has stuck up for
other people but always ran away not
because he didn't care about these
people but because he was genuinely
terrified and that's sort of the key to
who's up for me I was totally sold on
his character after his introduction
during the syrup villager but during
Barrett a he barely participated as
Sanji was receiving center stage
treatment as well as all the crazy stuff
that happened then so when he got his
chance to shine in this arc it really
helps solidify him as one of my favorite
characters in this series he's a
terrified regular guy that sees the
danger in everything he has his talents
and interest sure but he is by no means
a physically gifted fighter meaning by
acting as the others do despite being
terrified and not as well prepared it
makes him the most courageous character
in the entire series and when he finally
got the win in this arc against the fire
stronger opponent using his clever
tactics I actually left from my seat and
shed a tear for him because I knew how
much it must have meant to him I am
aware that he's a fictional character
but it did mean a lot to me in that
moment how he finally felt validated as
a warrior taking his first step towards
his dream despite all of these wonderful
things orders successfully performed
here I do find one aspect of this arc to
be well I don't want to say lacking but
not nearly as good as the rest of it has
been and that's the fight scene which
ended this arc between luffy and arlo
when it comes to scripting a fight scene
Oda is once again very good but I
wouldn't say exceptional like he is with
character writing dialogue even previous
fights and world building during the
battle with our lungs some of the set
pieces were interesting like him jumping
into the water or launching himself out
of it at Luffy but apart from that I
don't really think anything stands out
to me in direct contrast with that we
have his fight with Don Creek inter ovum
between these bursts of battle between
the two characters were other fights
character introductions schemes
strategies personal pride and the story
of Luffy proving himself to Creek and
that's ignoring all the other backhand
forts and struggles throughout that
final conclusion but with the fight with
are long it felt distinctly
one-dimensional to me especially when
you compare the two side-by-side I am
pression was that Arlen was supposed to
be this imposing impenetrable force
something unlike anything Luffy has ever
experienced someone to really push him
and give him a challenge but it didn't
really feel like Luffy was given that
much of a challenge with this guy at
least compared to the last main arc
battle with don krieg who pushed him to
his limits
now there's the obviously compelling
motivation Luffy has to fight him as
well as me the audience actually caring
about it but apart from simply fighting
him there wasn't much else to it and
unfortunately in addition to that during
this fight see I found some of the
panel's despite being drawn perfectly
fine to not flow very well for my taste
and in one or two cases sort of
confusing but even if I was to ignore
all of that I think the most obvious
shortcoming within this final fight
between Luffy and our lungs for me comes
in the fights climax within the
cartography room that Nami drew up all
the maps and ocean charts for the
evildoers throughout the years no not
true there would of course be a place
that Nami did all of this work that she
despised and was abused in however we
don't really ever see or hear about that
but like the rest of owners writing in
this chapter this room has no emotional
through-line for the readers and viewers
or at least it didn't for me and for the
climax to come from Nami quietly saying
thank you while crying in response to
see Luffy destroy the room and
ultimately liberate her it's a sweet
gesture and I did enjoy it but it had
nowhere near the impact I thought it
could have had and while the presence of
the room is perfectly fine the story
didn't really spend any time building
that up but one place it did spend time
exploring and familiarizing ourselves
with was the village Nami grew up in
Cocoa Village what if instead of
destroying a single room our along had
gone berserk and vowed to erase Coco
village from the face of the earth he
already went berserk in the fight but
very little changed before and after he
did go berserk really Coco village was
the place she spent almost a decade as a
slave to protect imagine if she was
faced with that threat and imagine if
Luffy was the only thing standing
between her home and certain destruction
there's tons of emotional resonance with
that and it could have even involved the
townspeople to stand up for themselves
alongside Luffy it's just a thought off
the top of my head but I thought it
could have worked better than a
cartography room
we had never been exposed to before no
I'm totally aware that this might seem
like a small nitpick and that's honestly
because it is but I think it stood out
to me as worth addressing because it
stands in direct contrast with an
utterly spectacular arc as a whole
however with all that said despite my
small issues with it our long park is
easily the best outing so far in one
piece and is composed of a series of
profoundly and massively handled moments
conflicts and scenes that truly touched
me and I'm sure will stay with me long
after I finished reviewing this series
[Music]
he gave Luffy his lucky straw hat was it
OSA shanks or Sonic lo coun arc chapters
96 to 100 what's funny about this short
but dense arc is that while I was
starting to believe I had any grasp on
the scope of Oda's writing he swerves me
yet again with something I alluded to in
the last review and I think this
particular choice an idea illustrates
exactly where owed his proclivities for
action and story lie for him it's very
much substance over style and nothing
demonstrates that more than the cover
art for each chapter he's released for
instance when it came to Dragonball by
Akira Toriyama
his cover art would be simply
representative largely of what would be
happening in this week's chapter or
something unrelated but Eiichiro Oda has
decided to tell his own secondary story
and subplot using the cover pages of his
chapters and if you line them up side by
side and one after the other they tell
the story of bugging the clown after his
defeat the hands of Luffy how he came to
meet a new business partner and how he
regained his foothold as a threat in
society it's funny it's character rich
and it's a whole lot of work and not to
mention vital for this story arc to work
and I say vital not only because it's
necessary for you to understand Bucky's
presence in this arc with the new and
improved lady Evita but because this is
the mini arc that showed me that I
really have no idea what the hell is
gonna happen whether it be through
character rich dialogue was always
buying swords that reminds him of his
childhood rival and friend the
intimidating reveal of Captain smoker
and that's not a joke name that's
actually his name the reintroduction of
an older more grizzled red haired shanks
and the unveiling of a mysterious
gentleman that has an invested interest
in the progression of Luffy and his gang
to say this arc has a lot to cover is an
absolute understatement I had to read it
twice to make sure I got everything and
spoiler alert
I didn't again thanks to cover art we
are reminded that this isn't like a
typical manga where villains and
characters get forgotten about once
their arc is done this is a fully
realized world and the characters who
are off screen are mu
around living their lives too and
because of this one pieces world feels
so alive I have no idea what's going to
happen next two Zorro's got new swords
Luffy was rescued from gold Rogers
shopping block and the next stop is the
grand freaking line and they're sailing
during a storm that was started by a man
that I think has the power to control
the weather maybe he's one of the seven
warlords of the grand line that was
mentioned at the beginning of the r-la
arc yeah I remember that one of it
this series is absolutely not in the
best way possible and I honestly have no
idea what's next
I have so many questions at this point
in the story like who are Luffy's
parents and why haven't we seen them
what does the D and monkey D Luffy stand
for who were nabis biological parents in
fact we don't really know anything about
any of the group's parents apart from us
ops whose father we know still operates
with shanks I have no idea what's to
come on this journey would probably end
up cycling through all the seven wards
at some point during the Grand Line and
I'm sure a variety of devil fruit would
play a large role - maybe you can
stockpile them who knows aside from my
crackpot theories at this point I can
see why so many of you are excited for
me to discover these arcs of the show
there's a very real feeling of
progression increased stakes and an
emotional maturity that the shown in
genre of that age often didn't and in a
lot of ways still doesn't employ in fact
the more that I read one piece the more
I'm convinced that it's actually an
adult's emotional comedy disguised as a
children's action manga and that's not
to say that kids can't love this series
- it's just typically things don't get
this nuanced when it comes to emotional
punchlines in a series of this type and
in the case of the Ireland Park Ark for
the entire thing to hinge on the
delivery of chapter 81 emotional
send-off I think it takes a lot of
confidence in your writing which I'm
sincerely happy oda has i thought the
decision for the ark to largely center
around nami struggle with allowing
others into her life to help her
situation was an inspired choice
creating for me one of the most
beautiful page turns i have ever in my
life experienced trust is a really
compelling theme to Center a story
around and I loved every moment of this
one and its execution but at the end of
the day I was only reading this story
alone in my dark room at the
twenty-eight and it still managed to
evoke emotions from me I haven't felt
since I was a young kid watching the
story that would later change my life
and because of that while I do
appreciate this story immensely I can't
begin to imagine the impact a story like
this with the lessons morals and
dialogue it has had on those of you
watching right now that grew up with it
I can't wait to see what's next
I've been told not Marc and thank you so
much for watching
[Music]